Desde hace dos años este profesor
distribuye canastas básicas en este
barrio Popular en la periferia de Río de
Janeiro son donaciones realizadas por
amigos y desconocidos comenzamos este
trabajo en medio de la pandemia pero no
fue por causa de la pandemia los vecinos
aquí ya estaban desempleados llegamos a
donar 153 canastas por mes pero hoy no
conseguimos más de 100 porque las
personas que está abandonando ya no
están en condición de seguir haciéndolo
tres de cada diez brasileños tienen que
lidiar con la inseguridad alimentaria es
decir que no tienen suficiente comida
para sus familias es el caso de Ana
Cristina perdió el empleo hace nueve
meses esa canasta supone una ayuda
importante en su mermada economía
harina arroz frijoles aceite
se llenó mi armario Qué bueno lo está
esperando se estima que cerca de 33
millones de brasileños actualmente no
tienen como alimentarse desde que llegó
bolsonaro la situación está difícil yo
misma pared de trabajar el salario de mi
marido fue reducido para que no lo
despidiesen él tuvo que aceptar porque
ya tenemos más de 40 años no hay Hacia
dónde correr porque no hay empleo Además
del hambre la destrucción de la amazonía
es otro problema que ha crecido Brasil
registra la peor deforestación desde
2007 el año pasado el superintendente de
la Policía Federal en el estado de
Amazonas realizó una Macro operación
contra el tráfico ilegal de madera y
acusó al ex ministro de medio ambiente
de estar vinculado a los empresarios
incriminados Poco después fue exonerado
hoy el comisario saraiba es candidato Al
Congreso Nacional espera combatir desde
brasi los crímenes ambientales a golpes
de ley el legado del gobierno bolsonaro
para la amazonía es la destrucción es la
complicidad con el crimen organizado que
destruye la amazonía intentando culpar a
los Indígenas a los periodistas a los
indigenistas a todas aquellas personas
que están allí para combatir el crimen
como si ella estuviesen la culpa de ser
víctimas la economía también se ha visto
impactada hoy la deuda pública ha
crecido
dos puparos registra los mejores datos
de los últimos siete años situándose del
9,3